[Music]
um okay guys and girls and girls thank
you Jesus representation matters mm-hmm
y'all have Steve Tiger King right yes
that was the greeting 14 [ __ ] watch the
whole finished red yes you get my trash
people but it gets crazy it's crazy
we take your word for it oh that's like
me bailing out a game of Thrones you
know how much you know how much [ __ ] I
got from that because I was like this
first and say we cared about you did you
guys get to the part where I mean you
guys don't carry ruin it no you get to
the power at the Super Bowl Joe actually
killed himself
oh yeah I mean we heard about it that's
it's crazy
the show is [ __ ] the tall guy right
yeah it's the best comedy I've ever seen
and these people are real here so don't
even know how you guys could not finish
that and when he ran for governor bro
come on oh so good but there are I have
I can't do it yeah she can do you
watching this Joyce bells are halfway
through shows always trash trash people
can't watch trash things I guess season
8 all me of gamma thoughts every other
cell is trash he doesn't know me you
like the only trash season of it yeah
that's true you were defending the
ending I was yeah before I even saw it
you said that's the real Daenerys the
whole time used to be in real Cersei
right now she's hot I thank you okay so
I have some updates to do would you like
to hear I do
I guess Harold Baskins favorite
character oh no no no the word hello cat
you can do some [ __ ]
you hater the monkey here yeah she
[ __ ] got Joey exotics Animal
Farm no like she body her she's got a
war
by the judge so we've got given to her
his worst nightmare of getting she's
dead hero Baskins now legally owns Joe
exotics when this happened
damn I heard the news almost like like
where were you when the news happened
like when Kennedy got shot like when we
land on the moon [ __ ]
you were there at a target getting Kenny
food and this white guy to his trash ass
wife was like baby baby baby you're not
gonna believe this [ __ ]
Carol Baskins she got all jokes on its
farm she's like you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me like it was like they were
shopping for cheetahs during the cheetah
section it was amazing
they saw kitty litter and she toes on
the sea mile it was target for it I was
exploring new target okay damn
dojo exotic is in prison right yes for
how long it's still in prison for in
case you don't know he is in prison
currently for attempting to hire a hit
man to kill Carol a basket that's not
Carol Baskins
had a case that was being real big and
it wasn't reopened but they were looked
into it the statute of limitations have
passed but it has been determined that
her husband's will was forged mmm which
is highly suspicious
so then why does she get the
thingamabobs because it's statute of
limitations it's the Wills already been
carried out she could walk in the public
square and be like I killed him and they
couldn't do well that she she couldn't
do because they have not investigated
her for killing it but then the will has
been forged so she could be like oh I
forged the will and she fine yeah
what are you sure that's okay they try
to get you for murder and then they said
oh no and yeah I do kill yeah you can't
do that that's the double jury what if
she was a diplomat from a different
country then she has diplomatic immunity
we watch the same movies I just remember
that line the both Christmas movies I
think it watch The Dictator something
what but oh but legal of it yeah I knew
that I knew that I just got confused for
a second but that's a loophole right so
in other countries if you if you're a US
ambassador or some [ __ ] you have
diplomatic immunity so you can commit
crimes in our country and they won't
prosecute you
what well Carol Baskins have a different
set of rules and then they they don't do
like the US justice system they go well
sort it out yeah and then they sort out
their own differently it sorted out
Steve yeah maybe but sometimes it's
nothing yep so I went to a military High
School and then there's a bunch of
diplomats kids like ambassador Italy's
kid a bachelor bachelor rushes kid went
there and then these fools will go out
and go street races they get locked up
and they just get a phone call and they
just get because of the diplomatic
immunity diplomatic immunity
cuz what would happened they would get
arrested and that they got charged the
[ __ ] Google world huh and I don't
know but they just untouchable it's like
it's almost like they could do whatever
the [ __ ] they want that's the dream well
she also got awarded several cabins and
vehicles she got a bunch of meth like
magnets she got and also I don't know if
you remember but Jeff Lowe Oh currently
owns Joe exotics tiger zoo was still
opening um I don't know if it's open
around but it's now gonna be her
sanctuary why does she get it because of
the lawsuit yeah financial damages and
they order a bunch of money and then
they couldn't pay yeah and so instead of
appealing Jeff flow is instead gonna put
all his energy into building a new Tiger
themed attraction he owns jokes out of
one of the guys that watch it oh yeah
you didn't watch that's right is he the
guy without the lake's
no he's the guy with the affliction
father in the bandana to bend down
with the Gods missing teeth here's true
religion jeans they didn't even get
there
it didn't get so he would go to Venice
with a little tiger pup so he could meet
girls and [ __ ] them mm-hmm oh how do you
get that oh we didn't get there you guys
not pushing it on us doing it to the
good parts yeah you didn't get any of
the good parts you got was like a taste
and then you decided not to even like
that flavor yeah he looks like a guy
who's like yo dude they should bring
back Tony Hawk's Pro Skater those
afflictions a little bit oh great that's
the [ __ ] best [ __ ] revenge ever
like someone tries to kill you and then
you take all of their property pretty
good that's what happened to the guy
that was just had Tigers and was [ __ ]
hella girls guy still has his his Tigers
oh yeah white points like that is like
the coolest waste or is there any
movement on the whole practice of having
tiger and mole parks yeah what was it
all for nothing
nothin it was just for our entertainment
I'm fine with that
yeah yeah I thought the whole point was
to show us about animal cruelty Carol
Baskins is you heard whole thing is
sanctuary
so like the Tigers that have been held
captive they'd be put down
they're not breeding you know just to
let them like live out their life and so
she's probably gonna turn in his zoo
into a sanctuary do we know if that's
real though or if she's also she's not
breathing but she did she killed her
husband yeah she killed her husband and
she probably bred but he's not a tiger
mm-hmm she didn't breed with her that's
more wrong breeding Tigers or killing he
bargained what did he do to her that's
what I'm good
Libra with no money that's briefly he
was gonna continue breeding Tigers so
that's fun about also make straight men
gay too right yeah that's the power
through metal through man okay that's
she that's the caveat Wow yeah he did
cheat cuz yeah who we didn't want to do
it for me yeah basically none of these
people are good people
oh no they're all trans people for sure
yeah that's what's so good and I know
when they're all getting married that
[ __ ] was the best sake well compared to
Game of Thrones like in made certain
character alignment with other Gary
that's what makes me so like we all they
do TV shows like this and also my mom
makes me go I don't quite understand
when people like they watch a movie and
they go oh that's too slapstick I'm like
there's even crazier [ __ ] than what you
guys listen it was a scripted I would
have been like they went too far yeah
but the fact that it's real I was like
crazier than what you can ever write
yeah yeah you know they're doing a
scripted version right yeah of Tiger
king why I know me too
and now that Danny McBride is hot Castle
is actually got I heard it's Nicolas
Cage oh that's pretty funny yeah that's
funny actually I think we dope I thought
Spade was reported been good for it I
about Danny McBride would have been the
best for it oh that's good you see a
little more sucked in lose some weight
you like meth ear yeah yeah yeah that
day was a little bit perfect
her perfect day look at you dude you
love it why the [ __ ] you lie in out of
all the things that have happened lately
you guys doing these puns makes you want
to leave whatever so what else is going
on in there I know we really positive
the conversation was fine that was a
good one I can't make heads or tails of
this
you know what I can't just sit here and
deny people that's wrong
hey yo you gotta be kidding me dude hate
you you just - you just earned your
stripes I know that's the joke what's
the joke now we're just repeating what
they said you can't keep copying Nicky
you being a cheetah we can keep attack I
wish we keep a tabby of all these jokes
oh yeah it's getting specific now hmm is
a furry situation
okay okay this is cringes [ __ ] I'm
stopping I think I'm just gonna hold my
breath with this I was that was a good
ending cuz we held our breath and a
different episode so you got to watch
the others to get that joke
[Music]